point about Hamas that really struck me
I think this phenomenon about sort of
boasting about your brutality is
something that goes even beyond the
Nazis think about it when the Nazis
established death camps not the
concentration camps because
concentration camps were labor camps but
death camps were gas Chambers right and
you'll notice that not a single death
camp is in Germany right every death
camp is in Poland or the occupied
territories now why is that because the
Nazis didn't want to show it to the
Germans they were not in that sense
proud of what they were doing and so
that is a little different from
terrorist exhibitionism that we see
these days where a terrorist group
Revels in the amount of Carnage that
they've caused almost as if that is a
measure of their effectiveness wow who
would have thought Hamas could get into
Israel with a thousand guys coming to
you know imaginatively from the sky even
though the Nazi analogy can be overdone
in this case we might even be seeing
things that are in some senses worse